welcome to this video this is g NK g NK
I or 12 1230 you never know yeah and
some of the Flex are not on there
anymore i don't know sometimes it's
weird don't really know what happened
there i also try to get my my flag back
but it didn't work i don't know what
what happened ok we have that I the on
McCutchen a variation of them of the
French do you play that it was Bishop 2c
69 27 I don't know yeah let's just let's
just play and then see what happens
looks looks okay to me putting the
bishop there on the long diagonal night
on d 7 I don't have what I don't have is
the C porn yeah but still I can go to h5
okay let's let's start with that I was
just thinking that c4 queen age 5 this
this might have some issues with 95 but
I have also Queenie form
yeah that's a bit tricky but well he
does not want to play Bishop d3 anyway
and then maybe threatening I mean Luke g
895 there is some pressure on this long
diagonal it's not so easy for y2 to
handle a bit surprised that you went for
that now I'm directly threatening stuff
should have three looks looks kind of
shaky the G file canon rube g8 very
quickly and he really has some issues
here with the King position maybe ok so
just Rock g8 right but is already really
dangerous Wow
okay so 95 is this the simple way to do
it on 95 looks very strong already yeah
I don't know t 5 mm I wonder is there
some sacrificial way to do it rook g2
for example look G to King g2g a check
yeah isn't this isn't a strong remain
let's do it it looks it looks winning to
me
Jay King h1 Queen h3 is really easy and
here the snide g4 which run shine to a
huge discovered check on GG on sorry
group on the G file I really was very
relaxed about asking positioner with
Bishop d3 and those moves okay so he
wants to escape hmm yeah 93 CSE escaping
with with King to King to f4 it's really
hard to believe
mmm but I don't see a maid at the moment
just kind of funny now check here i have
got nice GG to check now g to check to
check kinky for it looks that looks
totally crazy but where's the maid I
don't see the maid is there some other
way to do it this is the repetition
check that should it ready this movers
is the one but how am I going to meet
him I don't see it kind of kind of
embarrassing probably right she took
kingly for Queen f5 there is no made
remarkable
you might escape him
yeah I don't see a maid I don't see one
Queen f5 King takes III don't even have
a check available check really really
amazing check
Kingda for I mean he's really escaping
on c3 as weird as it looks you can just
play king before in this position and
end and do end escape hi morning he just
escapes hard to believe but it's the
case i can give this chick here King c3
and then I don't even have a check
check amazing I'm just the hope I just
have I'm down everything he just escaped
with the king I can't believe it
unbelievable Jim maybe I was always
probably just totally blind what they're
there wasn't a [ __ ] I was this is
giving away the Queen for no particular
reason now I'm going down on 25 seconds
shy so this is going to be a big issue
anyway check that was much better this
chick the move before you getting the
getting the night or some other material
hmm yeah will be will be tricky because
that time situation but check position
is very nice of course check check check
check check check mate Wow whoo that
game was kind of hard to believe all in
all you have a day I didn't see a check
made come on this was probably like one
of the most embarrassing moves and moves
games ever okay yeah I can take one of
three which is kind of it's not really
difficult yeah I was just thinking okay
Queen g4 and black wins anyway but
that's probably not the case queena
three I didn't see Queen f3a but I
didn't look for a better move because
squeegee was just wrong but it's of
course not as strong as Queen f3 yeah
bishop here aid and assist 95 g5 so how
do I win now Queen g6 is what the
conversing and look g2 is amazingly not
so clear hmm okay
but this is winning but how exactly ok
so the comb just wants to take on f1
yeah yeah it just wants to take him ok
yeah well this is this a certainly a
point yeah after I get this and yes who
recapture probably the Queen hang so
there is no time for any and now
computer wants to take him and just a
tech in this position ok I already have
two pawns for a piece and it's of course
a marvel as a tech yeah it's actually
minus 7 according to the computer yeah
probably but what is my friend I know I
know I'm threatening actually queen age
6 because there is no king e four so I
am and if I check here just here this is
this is very strong queen age 6 now is a
big threat and here check there are yeah
this is easy night everyone know and he
is escaping right they are here white
wins this King in the middle of the
board is is immune to immune to attacks
it's really remarkable check yeah now
I'm just just totally lost but for some
reason he allowed 94 I don't know if you
just move the king it's just over check
chayanne it's it's it still nothing
great but he gave me tons of stuff Queen
D for one move earlier of course was
better yeah black wins but I had to hit
the time issue with somehow it was okay
it was working Wow okay thanks for
watching